[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance
présente état de santé
[Musique]
des bactéries eucolies dans des pizzas
des salmonelles dans des chocolats et
des Listeria dans des fromages au
printemps dernier les scandales
sanitaires se sont enchaînés avec pour
certains des conséquences graves deux
enfants sont décédés et près de 80
personnes ont été hospitalisées en
France aujourd'hui quand je fais à
manger c'est avec la boule au ventre
savoir est-ce que mes enfants vont être
malade
dans les usines la réglementation en
matière de sécurité sanitaire est
pourtant claire et les mesures d'hygiène
sont strictes mais le risque zéro
n'existe pas alors les chercheurs se
penchent sur de nouvelles solutions
contre les intoxications alimentaires
alors on peut qualifier les
bactériophages de gentil virus et qui
infectent les bactéries en particulier
les bactéries qui sont pathogènes pour
l'être humain en attendant comme en
tirer les leçons des scandales
sanitaires passés intoxication
alimentaire faut-il en avoir peur c'est
le thème de ce nouveau numéro d'état de
santé
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cet état
de santé est-ce qu'il vous est déjà
arrivé de regarder votre assiette d'un
drôle d'air avec méfiance en fait 48%
48% des Français sont beaucoup plus
méfiants ne font plus confiance en
réalité dans l'industrie agroalimentaire
depuis les derniers scandales en
particulier du printemps 2022 on va en
parler avec notre invité bonjour Cyril
Parmentier bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes néphrologue en
pédiatrie à la PHP bon vous ne voyez pas
c'est que des enfants d'ailleurs à force
de parler intoxication alimentaire
traiter intoxication alimentaire vous
même quand vous regardez votre assiette
ça vous arrive de temps de le nez ou pas
je suis vigilante et encore plus pour
l'assiette de mes enfants tirer le
parmentier combien de personnes sont
hospitalisées chaque année dans votre
service pour intoxication alimentaire
alors dans mon service passe plus
particulièrement ses enfants à atteints
de un syndrome hémolytique et urhémique
je dirais que parents à peu près une
quinzaine définition du syndrome
syndrome c'est donc cette fameuse
maladie qui est qui est liée à un
échecoli donc qui a été ingéré par les
enfants et c'est un certain type de
Charlie chacoli qui va être producteur
de ce qu'on appelle une toxine c'est
cette fameuse toxine qui va entraîner
des symptômes classiques d'une
gastro-entérite d'une intoxication
alimentaire mais qui va aussi aller
attaquer d'autres organes et parfois
régulièrement les reins et donc c'est
pour ça que nous en tant que néphrologue
pédiatre on est très sensibilisé à cette
maladie là on voit bien que vous êtes
une spécialiste on regarde votre
parcours
[Musique]
Cyrielle Parmentier est néphrologue
pédiatre à l'hôpital Armand Trousseau de
la PHP elle est spécialisée dans la
prise en charge des enfants atteint de
maladies rénales c'est donc dans son
service qui ont été hospitalisés
certains des 55 enfants qui ont
contracté un syndrome hémolytique et
urémique après avoir consommé une pizza
surgelée contaminée au printemps 2022 la
plupart des enfants qu'elle suit pour
ces formes graves d'intoxication ont
moins de 5 ans
alors docteur Parmentier vous avez donc
des enfants sous votre garde dans votre
service pourquoi les enfants sont-ils
plus exposés à ce type de risque c'est
une bonne question on a l'impression en
tout cas les hypothèses qui sont
formulés c'est principalement que les
petits enfants parce que c'est souvent
en a tendance à dire des moins de 5 ans
même si on a aussi et notamment dans
l'épidémie avec Buitoni on a eu des
enfants entre à 5-12
c'est plus en lien avec la fragilité de
la muqueuse intestinale donc on a
l'impression que les enfants sont plus
susceptibles de justement d'être d'être
sensibilisé à cette toxine là
particulièrement plus que des adultes
mais ça peut aussi parfois on peut aussi
avoir des adultes dans les services pour
adultes et on sait que des personnes
immunodéprimées ou des personnes très
âgées vont aussi avoir cette fragilité
là donc quand on parle intoxication
alimentaire on a souvent le sentiment
qu'il s'agit quoi d'une grosse gastro
ben voilà on a une mauvaise digestion
c'est très très grave en réalité parfois
et vous vous avez eu récemment un décès
d'enfant dans votre service souffert on
a eu au bas au printemps dernier des
situations en effet qui sont beaucoup
plus graves qui ne semble
gastro-entérite parce que cette fameuse
toxine dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure elle va aller toucher des
organes et des organes qui sont dit des
organes vitaux donc les reins avec des
enfants qui sont plus en capacité
d'uriner qui ont besoin parfois même
d'une dialyse pendant plusieurs jours
plusieurs semaines mais aussi on peut
avoir une atteinte qui peut être au
niveau du cœur ou au niveau du cerveau
et dans ces cas là on peut avoir en
effet des conséquences qui peuvent être
dramatiques avec malheureusement des
séquelles voir des décès heureusement
c'est absolument pas la majorité de nos
patients heureusement c'est rare mais ça
fait partie des complications exactement
quels sont les principales bactéries et
aliments responsables de ces
intoxications potentiellement mortelles
la plupart du temps c'est ce fameux
Escherichia coli donc on appelle aussi
eu colis
et donc c'est l'ingestion de produits en
provenance classiquement des bovins le
plus souvent c'est la vache et donc la
vache va être porteuse de ce fameux
oeucoli mais la vache s'emporte elle
très bien et lorsque vous allez ingérer
des produits
issus de cette vache là qui était
porteuse de ce colis et ben l'homme est
donc comme on l'a dit les petits enfants
vont eux être susceptibles de faire ce
fameux Shu parce que la toxine va aller
s'attaquer à tous ces organes à quoi
faut-il faire attention quels sont les
symptômes que son enfant ou l'enfant
d'un autre peut être victime au départ
ça peut s'apparenter à une gastro
classique comme vous l'avez dit le plus
souvent on va avoir tout de même des
enfants qui ont des symptômes qui
peuvent être déshydratés donc c'est des
enfants qui sont affaiblis qui ont du
mal à s'alimenter parce qu'ils ont une
diarrhée et cette diarrhée la
particularité de cette diarrhée et ce
qui peut alerter c'est que c'est une
diarrhée dans lequel on peut avoir du
sang cette toxine a abîmé les intestins
et vous pouvez voir du sang et donc les
enfants arrivent jusqu'à nous par les
urgences ou par le pédiatre qu'il a
c'est alerté en se disant tiens c'est
pas une gastro comme d'habitude là je le
trouve pas bien je le trouve pas le
parce qu'on peut aussi avoir ce qu'on
appelle une anémie donc c'est des
enfants qui sont très pâles là il faut
faire une prise de sang et c'est
classiquement c'est la prise de sang qui
va nous guider mais la prise de sang
elle est bien entendu pas faite pour
tous les enfants qui ont une gastro mais
pour certaines situations que les
pédiatres que les urgentistes
connaissent bien d'un enfant qui va
moins bien alors il y a évidemment les
intoxications qui sont produites par des
produits qu'on achète transformés mais
il y a aussi des tas de gestes qu'on
peut faire à la maison pour éviter de
décupler le risque je vous propose de
regarder cette infographie
[Musique]
en général quand un plat ressemble à ça
c'est que quelque chose ne va pas mais
parfois un aliment à beau être
appétissant il peut cacher une très
mauvaise surprise des bactéries comme
les salmonelles les Listeria ou les
échelles colis qui peuvent être très
dangereuses heureusement il est possible
de les éviter ou de les neutraliser
[Musique]
ensuite il faut se laver les mains et
utiliser des ustensiles propres après la
manipulation de la viande crue c'est la
même chose pour éviter de contaminer
d'autres aliments
passons à la cuisson c'est une étape
très importante pour tuer les
micro-organismes ce steak haché doit
être cuit à cœur pendant environ 2
minutes à 65 degrés surtout pas de
viande rosée si elle est destinée à une
femme enceinte un jeune enfant ou à une
personne immunodéprimée après le repas
les restes vont directement au
réfrigérateur et doivent être consommés
dans les trois jours
hygiène cuisson et conservation sont
donc les trois principes à garder à
l'esprit pour tenir les intoxications à
l'écart
[Musique]
alors donc le stockage abonne
température se laver les mains avant
après tout opération lavé les ustensiles
est-ce qu'il y a un autre conseil que
vous nous donneriez il faut juste pas
oublier que la congélation ne va pas
protéger ne va pas éliminer cette
fameuse bactérie c'est vraiment l'amour
70 c'est que d'ailleurs comme ça que
vous conservez vos bactéries dans les
grands laboratoires c'est en les mettant
au congélateur donc vous avez raison
je crois que vous préconisez que les
jeunes enfants ne puissent toucher les
animaux comment on peut empêcher un
enfant toucher un poney ou même une
vache bien sûr quand vous allez à la
ferme avec votre loulou vous allez pas
l'empêcher de toucher les animaux mais
vous attrapez pas la pomme qui est
tombée par terre au contact au contact
des excréments des animaux vous lavez
avant vous lavez les mains de de vos
enfants est-ce que vous avez noté
d'ailleurs des changements
d'alimentation dans les familles en
matière de sûreté alimentaire je dirais
que l'agroalimentaire est partout donc
on a vraiment des une famille qui qui
vont utiliser les produits qui sont
préparés parce que tout le monde
travaille tout le monde est pressé et
c'est normal on fait tout ça et puis à
l'inverse on va avoir des familles qui
vont avoir envie de faire tester des
choses parce qu'on va leur dire ah il
faut éduquer le goût alors éduquer le
goût ça peut être avoir envie de donner
du fromage au lait cru parce que le
Saint-Marcellin c'est bon bah non pour
les tout-petits par exemple on va dire à
ces familles là vous avez envie de leur
éduquer le goût mais il y a certains
produits notamment le fromage au lait
cru et ben non pas pour les tout-petits
le fromage au lait crevé
on a tendance à dire pas avant 5 ans ah
bon pas de cuisson Marcellin il faut
surtout pas le donner à ses enfants non
on a assez peu finalement de pédagogie
autour de et c'est pour ça qu'on est là
parce qu'il faut qu'on communique auprès
des familles parce que la plupart des
familles qui arrivent elles nous disent
je savais pas y a-t-il des raisons de
craindre des failles dans la sûreté la
chaîne alimentaire justement je vous
propose de regarder le reportage de
Marianne Cazeau
[Musique]
quand l'heure du repas approche
l'angoisse se fait sentir dans la
cuisine de Gwenaëlle Caron car depuis
qu'elle a failli perdre sa fille pour
cette mère de famille tout aliment peut
contenir un danger mortel
ah j'ai plus confiance du tout parce que
on sait pas aujourd'hui si ça va et puis
ça se trouve dans un mois on va nous
dire ah bah non finalement ce que vous
avez mangé ça allait pas aujourd'hui
quand je fais à manger c'est avec la
boule au ventre
savoir est-ce que mes enfants vont être
malades
c'est en consommant une pizza buttonie
au printemps dernier qu'elle a contaminé
sa fille depuis elle se lave sans cesse
les mains atteinte d'un syndrome dit Shu
à seulement 9 mois Inaya a passé 25
jours dans le coma
la petite fille s'en est sorti mais
garde des séquelles elle pourrait avoir
besoin d'une greffe de reins dans
quelques années
[Musique]
traumatisé Gwenaëlle Caron consulte tous
les matins ce site qui répertorie les
retraits rappels de produits avec le
sentiment que tout ce qui est issu de
l'agroalimentaire n'est pas sûr alors
ces craintes sont-elles justifiées pour
le savoir il faut s'intéresser au paquet
hygiène la réglementation européenne
pour la filière agroalimentaire en
vigueur depuis 2006 elle donne des
obligations aux entreprises en matière
de traçabilité de retrait de produits et
d'informations des autorités les
industriels sont tenus responsables de
la sécurité alimentaire ils doivent
notamment effectuer des autocontrôle
réguliers à tous les stades de la
fabrication
l'Agence nationale de sécurité sanitaire
de l'alimentation a participé à
l'élaboration de cette réforme ce
changement de paradigme il est très
important avec le paquet hygiène et il
remet la responsabilité sur les
entreprises et ça remet l'accent sur les
bonnes pratiques d'hygiène sur
finalement la prévention les mesures de
maîtrise que l'on doit mettre en place
pour prévenir la contamination et pas
simplement dire j'ai fait un test il est
négatif je ne suis pas responsable c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles les
infections alimentaires sont stables
voire en légère baisse depuis 10 ans
néanmoins le risque zéro n'existe pas
comme l'a montré l'affaire des laits
infantiles contaminés en 2018 ou celle
des petites habittionnées qui a touché
la famille de Gwenaëlle Caron
malgré les mesures d'hygiène Street les
failles existent comme le prouve ses
photos publiées par Mr Mondialisation en
2021 elle montre l'usine de Caudry où
était fabriquée les pizzas butoni dans
un état d'insalubrité inquiétant d'après
une enquête de disclose un rapport de la
répression des fraudes datant de 2020
pointait déjà des manquements
le plafond est malpropre des souillures
marrons sont visibles au niveau des
poutres et sur les parois murales vous
savez au jour d'aujourd'hui si j'ai ma
cuisine qui est moitié moins sale que ça
on est susceptible de m'enlever mes
enfants pour manger et eux
rien c'est pas normal aujourd'hui il
faut plus jamais que ça arrive ce genre
de choses
non
Gwenaëlle Caron a décidé de porter
plainte ce n'est pas la première fois
que des grands groupes comme Nestlé
propriétaire de butoni sont touchés par
des scandales sanitaires l'ONG food
watch on a fait sa spécialité
pour Karine Jacquemart malgré une
réglementation claire certaines
entreprises ne remplissent pas leurs
obligations alors c'est aux autorités de
jouer leur rôle
la confiance aveugle c'est faire prendre
des risques inconsidérés au
consommateurs et on voit bien que dans
le système aujourd'hui de d'un manque de
transparence et le climat d'impunité où
on a des entreprises comme Nestlé qui
manifestement se croient au dessus des
lois ça n'est pas possible de s'appuyer
que sur la confiance aveugle et les
autocontrôles des entreprises il faut
qu'elle sente que il y a des contrôles
sur elle qu'elles doivent rendre des
comptes et qu'il y ait des sanctions
dissuasives or les moyens des autorités
de contrôle sont en baisse en 2021 la
Direction Générale de l'Alimentation à
effectuer 48 800 contrôles de sécurité
alimentaire soit 16% de moins qu'en 2019
et la répression des fraudes a perdu
plus de 600 agents depuis 2007 pas de
quoi faire peur aux entreprises qui ne
respectent pas la réglementation il en
faudra plus pour restaurer la confiance
[Musique]
docteur Parmentier la maman qui est dans
le reportage de Marianne Cazot
évidemment les paralysée quand elle
achète elle se demande si elle va faire
du bien ou du mal à son enfant c'est
terrible comme évidemment comme idée
vous en rencontrez souvent des familles
qui après un tel traumatisme sont ainsi
vraiment
totalement désemparé c'est dur il y a un
avant et un après c'est des familles qui
sont hospitalisées une semaine avant
tout allait très bien et puis là voilà
il y a une hospitalisation parfois
longue parfois lourde donc on comprend
tout à fait cette famille il faut
arriver à reprendre confiance et puis
parfois changer les habitudes on voit
que cette maman ne fera probablement
plus de plus confiance pour le moment
aux produits préparés et elle va elle va
faire elle-même et nous on les
accompagne on les accompagne pour
reprendre voilà reprendre confiance dans
leur quotidien docteur Parmentier à
partir du moment où un enfant arrive
dans votre service et que vous
diagnostiquez une intoxication
alimentaire grave comment
Alertez-vous ceux qui peuvent être
concernés par ce problème on va aller
envoyer un écouvillon de sel donc dans
le ce qu'on appelle le centre de
référence donc nous on travaille avec
l'hôpital Robert Debré en Île-de-France
qui va essayer déjà de d'identifier
cette fameuse toxine et une fois qu'elle
est identifiée on va travailler main
dans la main avec santé publique France
ils vont de façon assez précautionneuse
appelée les familles et faire une
enquête qui peut être longue et
fastidieuse où ils vont répertorier tous
les aliments que l'enfant va pouvoir
avoir ingéré et c'est comme ça on
revient
des symptômes petit déjeuner déjeuner
dîner
c'est fastidieux c'est long pour les
familles mais elles comprennent et elles
jouent le jeu et on leur fait des
regroupements parce que on a quatre
familles qui ont mangé la même pizza
exactement et si on ne trouve pas des
coïncidences des correspondances des
similitudes et bien on n'a pas la
réponse et ben non et ça arrive
malheureusement
justement vous vous souciez des moyens
qui sont mis en oeuvre par la puissance
publique pour opérer des contrôles
nécessaires sur la chaîne
agroalimentaire et vous avez souhaité
demander à la députée Géraldine Bannier
député MoDem de la Mayenne si depuis
l'affaire Lactalis il y avait eu des
progrès en termes de prévention des
risques et elle vous répond
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'on avait relevé notamment
un dysfonctionnement au niveau des
procédures de retrait de rappel et donc
il y a eu quand même des des nouveautés
notamment via la loi egalim les
industriels doivent maintenant
communiquer aux autorités publiques tout
résultat d'auto contrôle qui est mauvais
que ce soit sur les produits ou sur
l'environnement donc on a quand même
renforcé cette procédure et puis il y a
des choses qui ont été mises en place
comme un site internet dédié au retrait
rappel
depuis avril 2021 donc rappel conso qui
aide quand même les consommateurs à
avoir une meilleure lisibilité des
produits retirés
[Musique]
docteur parlons un peu maintenant de des
soins que vous apportez en votre service
est-ce qu'il y a des traitements des
traitements efficaces contre les formes
d'intoxication que vous avez à traiter
la particularité de ce fameux chéri chat
colis c'est que on va devoir tendance à
dire c'est une bactérie je vais donner
des antibiotiques si vous donnez des
antibiotiques qui tuent les sheriches
acoly il va libérer sa toxine et donc
vous allez faire plus de mal que de bien
attendez répétez moi ça quand vous
donnez un antibiotique je vais libérer
l'antibiotique je vais tuer les chérisha
colis et lorsqu'il meurt il va libérer
des toxines comme une bombe à
fragmentation et donc vous allez faire à
ce moment-là plus de mal que de bien
puisque c'est cette fameuse toxine qui
va s'attaquer à nos organes cibles donc
la particularité de cette intoxication
alimentaire là ce Shu c'est que on est
assez démunis en termes de traitement
spécifique on a tendance à traiter les
conséquences mon enfant ne peut plus
uriner je vais le dialyser il a une
anémie je vais fusée mais je n'arrive
pas actuellement en tout cas en 2022 on
n'est pas capable de d'aller éliminer la
bactérie directement exactement et alors
qu'est-ce qu'elle produit vous traitez
les symptômes et que la bactérie elle
reste dans l'organisme mais elle s'en va
progressivement dans combien de temps ça
c'est pareil variable d'un enfant à
l'autre et donc ça peut prendre
plusieurs jours plusieurs semaines et
l'Europe il y a une autre piste de
traitement qui pourrait remplacer
justement les antibiotiques ce sont les
bactériophages je les ai découvert grâce
au reportage de Marianne Cazaux qui
s'est intéressée à cette nouvelle piste
reportage
[Musique]
alors que l'inventeur de la
pasteurisation veille ses murs
pourraient bien cacher une nouvelle
manière d'éliminer les bactéries
pathogènes de notre alimentation enfin
nouvelle pas vraiment alors on retrouve
ici
une collection de bactériophage qui ont
été isolées dans les années 40 à 80
c'est bactéries aux Fages appelé aussi
Fages sont des virus mangeurs de
bactéries ils ont été oubliés ici
pendant des dizaines d'années et pour
Laurent de Barbieux il mérite que l'on
s'intéresse à nouveau à eux face aux
infections alimentaires alors certes ils
ne sont pas très engageants ils
colonisent par exemple l'eau des égouts
ici celle de la région parisienne c'est
là où les bactéries sont les plus
nombreuses que l'on retrouve le plus de
bactériophages ils sont donc partout
autour de nous
c'est ça qui extraordinaire avec les
femmes il y en a tellement que on n'est
pas limité sur la quantité qu'on peut
isoler de l'environnement
regardons comment ces phages agissent
contre les bactéries comme les
salmonelles ou les Listeria il faut
mélanger un peu d'eau d'égouts et une
solution bactérienne après plusieurs
heures certaines bactéries ont disparu
laissant apparaître des petits ronds
transparents c'est ici qu'elles ont été
mangées par les Fages par-delà les
portes du laboratoire les bactériophages
pourraient être utilisés dans les
élevages pour limiter la propagation des
pathogènes parmi les animaux il y a
aussi l'application directe chez l'être
humain ou on peut dans le cas d'une
épidémie qui est en voie de
dissémination essayez de cerner cette
épidémie par la distribution à grande
échelle de solutions de bactériophages
dans une région donnée par exemple pour
ralentir le la dissémination de la
bactérie pathogène mais pour que cela
soit vraiment efficace il faudrait un
traitement préventif
c'est donc ce qu'a voulu tester le
chercheur sur des souris ces colonnes
représentent le tube digestif des
animaux avant une infection au
salmonelle à gauche les souris ont reçu
un traitement préventif de bactériophage
à droite le groupe contrôle qui n'en a
pas reçu lorsque l'on ajoute Salmonella
on voit très bien que la quantité de
salmonelle est extrêmement importante
dans le groupe qui n'a pas reçu de
bactériophage et elle est plus faible
dans le groupe qui a reçu le
bactériophage avec une réduction qui est
assez importante
même de manière préventive ces
bactériophages sont donc efficaces pour
tuer les pathogènes comme ils le font
sur cette image de microscope
électroniques néanmoins pour le moment
les phages ne sont utilisés en France
que dans les laboratoires de recherche
comme ici ou dans des cas très rares
d'impact thérapeutique alors finalement
compte-t-il de plus que les
antibiotiques qui s'attaquent aussi au
bactéries pour le savoir regardons de
plus près l'étude de Laurent Debarbieux
chaque couleur représente un type de
bonne bactéries que l'on trouve dans le
microbiote des animaux avec ou sans
bactériophages sa composition reste la
même à gauche et à droite
ne change rien à l'équilibre du
microbiote intestin et c'est important
car ces bonnes bactéries nous aident à
nous débarrasser des mauvaises bactéries
comme les salmonelles le temps est venu
pour les bactériophages d'être utilisés
puisque leur spécificité permet de ne
pas toucher à cette équilibre au
microbien d'aller vraiment cibler les
bactéries pathogènes contrario des
antibiotiques qui restent importants à
utiliser dans les infections
bactériennes mais pour lesquelles on
sait qu'aujourd'hui il y a des effets
secondaires sur ces fleurs microbiennes
les bactéries enfin sont encore en cours
d'études mais à l'heure de l'essor des
résistances aux antibiotiques il
pourrait bien prendre leur revanche sur
ces médicaments qui les ont éclipsés
depuis 1941 et reléguer sur une étagère
de l'Institut Pasteur
[Musique]
Parmentier bactériophages vous vous
suivez ça de près parce que
effectivement c'est une piste
prometteuse c'est vrai quand on voit le
reportage ça donne envie d'y attarder
nous en pratique cliniques on en utilise
pas c'est pas dans nos services ça fait
pas partie de notre quotidien
actuellement dans notre arsenal
thérapeutique peut-être que plus tard la
recherche voilà nous permettra de de les
utiliser mais en tout cas et encore une
fois voilà allez tuer cette fameuse
bactérie les toxines qui se libèrent je
ne sais pas dans quelle mesure les
bactériophages pourront être une aide
pour le fameux CHU peut-être que
l'avenir nous le dira vous verrez ça
j'espère avant de prendre votre retraite
dans très très longtemps Parmentier il y
a des bonnes et des mauvaises bactéries
il y a des bonnes et des mauvaises
bactéries c'est finalement toute la
problématique du microbiote comme vous
le savez on a beaucoup beaucoup de
bactéries et donc tout notre système
digestif est fait de plein de bactéries
et un système digestif sans bactéries
est un mauvais système digestif il y en
a qui qui nous protègent et là on
n'arrête pas de parler de ce fameux
hokoli mais tous les eaux colis ne sont
pas si toxiques et si dangereux
colis c'est ça heureusement alors
dernière question quand on a un aliment
transformé ou pas d'ailleurs sous les
yeux dans sa cuisine est-ce qu'il y a
des indices auxquels il faut faire très
attention pour éviter les données non
votre bon sens c'est-à-dire bien sûr
vous allez l'ouvrir vous allez le sentir
vous allez regarder la date de
péremption mais mais à l'oeil nu comme
ça non là ce dont on parle c'est pas
visible à l’œil nu ce colis on le verra
pas pas de parano encore une fois
exactement la majorité de ce qu'on mange
et sain et vous vous diriez pour finir
évitez les produits transformés au
maximum ou non non je dirais faite avec
votre absence
faites comme vous pouvez c'est toujours
facile de donner des injonctions de
famille et aux familles qui travaillent
et qui rentrent à 19h et qui ont pas le
temps de cuisiner on fait comme on et on
essaye de prendre du plaisir à table
avec des consignes simples bon vous avez
raison merci beaucoup de cet éloge de la
modestie et de toutes les informations
que vous nous avez données docteur
Parmentier merci beaucoup et à très vite
pour une prochaine émission d'état de
santé
[Musique]
elle s'est fait Assemblée nationale en
partenariat avec MGEN mutuelle santé
prévoyance vous a présenté état de santé
[Musique]